[Music]
Michelle Turner joins the party four
words for you shell Emma Watson vanity
mean come on right I got three for you
Hermione no more she's showing love it
yeah she's also showing up her singing
skills in the new live version of Beauty
and the Beast and we have all the
secrets behind the music
[Music]
Emma sings the classic seven-minute
opening number that was in the animated
version plus she gets a new original
song we see you know what is kind of the
story of Belle's life before you know
before she goes to the costume she meets
Beast
beauties that classic title tune was
sung by Angela Lansbury Celine Dion and
people Bryson did one for the original
movies credits and this time the duet is
with Ariana Grande and John Legend
[Music]
everyone envisions us in the studio
together but almost every time someone
doesn't do it these days we do it
separately we respect the song a lot and
we respect the original recording a lot
and Celine's actually back again on the
new soundtrack singing how does a moment
last forever a decision she discussed
with her late husband I kind of talked
to Renee and he said you should it was
an amazing privilege again Beauty and
the Beast brought me to where I am today
as a big part of Israel played a big
role especially Luke Evans takes on the
comical role of guest don't
[Music]
ever since I've told people that I play
guest only without any prompting will
come out with lines from the song Gaston
these one lines like I have I use
antlers in all of my enduring amount of
times I've had people come up with that
line and I didn't even remember that